I am the presiding officer of the
National Assembly for Wales and one of
my key roles is to ensure that all the
people of Wales are able to engage with
this Emily's work whether through the
Welsh or the English language and that's
why I'm working with Microsoft to create
a machine translation tool to help the
Assembly to meet our own language goals
it also put the Welsh language on the
world stage by providing a translation
tool that is available to any Microsoft
customer across the globe
but cavity Peter Nadal and one autumn
dream yet a gray initiate couple who you
thought they might wasan affair our
business and cally Jo got a new material
and a camera like arsenic my name is
Craig Stevenson and I work here at the
National Assembly for Wales and
bilingual live in Welsh and English but
my written Welsh is not strong as my
written English so currently I use a
web-based translation service to produce
first drafts but the development of this
microsoft translation toolkit which
actually sits on my machine is bound to
make me more efficient when i need to
produce written material in both
languages
I'm Simon I live in Hong Kong with my
wife near Microsoft translate is a great
tool to allow meet and learn ears first
language which is Welsh why not give it
a go yourself
the often very own eval or Microsoft a
very big thank you to everyone at
Microsoft for helping us develop this
exciting new tool the on Val